hi everyone all right we have the
ultimate TRS news to serve up because we
have a a chef a social media star and a
cookbook author one of my very favorites
his latest is texture over taste it's
our dear friend back to the show Joshua
Weiss it's a good time as always my
besty Rossy rossm hi hi hi I'm in this
book you guys it's so good I'm you guys
this is I love this book so much I
really love the themes of this book you
have creamy you have crunchy you have
aerated I I can't I was just saying to
Josh um that I he has tempora in here
which is one of my favorite things in
the world it's the first thing and it's
like you may me feel like there's a
chance you can do it 100% it's easy it's
fine you know it's just hot oil so you
can be careful
right telling you sat with this book all
weekend all right well Joshua friend of
the show we'd love to get into some food
news with you I'm excited well you're up
first story okay first up time out
reports you can now buy Chicago hot dog
flavored potato chips oh wow a classic
Chicago styled hot dog is dressed in
mustard green relish onions tomatoes
spicy peppers and pickle and a pickle
spear on a poppy seed bun that's what
they these chips taste like that all in
a chip I don't know about that so this
is supposed to taste like this you guys
you guys it
does it
does I mean I'm just going to have it's
transformative it is hot diggity dog it
tastes like a hot dog it
does it's like first it's like a little
bit faint the Chicago dog and then it
evolves right you're chewing the crunch
is going by and then I'm picking up a
little bit of mustard a little bit of
the pickle spear the pickle is like
there it's got sour and acid and I'm
loving it it's so good you guys who
makes these shout out oh shout out
they're right there who does that
Chicago style right
here box
Trot that's so good box Trot I'm single
and ready to
mingle all right next story Taste of
Home reports that
scey is the new food trend and right now
now what is swiy it's kind of exactly
what you think it's going to be it's
sweet and spicy mixed together as one
harmonious cute new piffy
word I like this Josh how do you feel
about these like food terms look I can
be a little bit of a stickler at times I
will be honest swiy it sounds nice cuz
it kind of sounds like my last name so
maybe I like it you know maybe a little
bit swiy weissy yeah that could be a
brand that could be a thing yeah well
scey is my DJ name little known fact but
it is and my f my favorite new word is
swet when it's sweet but still on my
diet right um I think we could also use
a little more swaly which is sweet and
salty cuz I really love like that ju
toos anything that's sweet and savory
could do it for me sweet and savory like
hot honey is having a major moment right
now or like old school pepper jelly do
you know ever have that oh I love pepper
jelly so much and that's scey right yeah
I mean like chocolate and steak I know
that's
coffee chocolate and steak hold on I
thought you were going to say chocolate
covered pretzels when I was in that I
was like cuz that's exactly what I
thought right chocolate steak well I've
done this like coffee chocolate rub on a
steak and added a little pepper and it
was a really really great result wow we
didn't see it coming but we're here for
the ride drew that sounds good I'm glad
you like it Cuisine yeah I dare to say
these these chips are delicious but they
stay with you a little bit it's
um okay worth it worth it but you're
going to smell it
[Music]
later